The other day me and my husband were talking about caramel apples
when our kids overheard our conversations.
They were begging me to try one since they've never had one before,
so I just decided to make them some today.
Started off by putting some skewers into Granny Smith apples
and blanching them in some hot water
for all the wax coating to come off.
After about 20 seconds I rub them down with a paper towel
just to make sure they were extra clean.
I pop those in my fridge to cool while I got started on my caramel.
We kept it really simple today with some brown sugar,
heavy cream, and some butter.
Melted all of that down while stirring it frequently,
and once it was melted, I pulled it off the stove,
added some vanilla and let it cool so it would thicken.
I was happy with the consistency.
I started dipping my cold apples into the caramel
and I made sure to repeat that process at least two or three times
to get a nice even coating on them.
I then put them in the fridge for about 30 minutes to set
and then it was time to slice them.
The kids were so excited and kept asking for more after the first.